wrong with being able to drink? Mr. Ease, what's wrong with staring out at the ocean
?
This week I've been immersed in
memories of a pitiful and elegant empire that perished over 100 years ago. It's a
lie, it's a lie, it's a lie. It's about the Kabane Temple.  I was
thinking the same thing. All
I did in the Empire was
cultivate poetry among idiots. Is
n't that quite an accomplishment? It's
rare for all of us to become court magicians.  I
finally got in as a replacement for my master when he retired, but the
dead man who got into the five fingers with his ability is different from Mr. Easy's, and I
feel like I'm in a hurry because of the designated technique of using directional materials.  My heart is pounding,
or rather, I ca
n't help but feel the magical power running through the veins of the leaves. Even
after 100 years, your tongue has not calmed down.
Does that mean that the longer you live through magic, the slower your growth will be?
[Music]
That
stupid disciple.  Maybe he remained a boy until the end,
isn't it? You'll always
remain a child, New Year's boy. You're
usually a very good boy, so when you're on the battlefield, you're a
different person. You're a good boy. You've
got a misunderstanding. That's a big
misunderstanding.  There's
one thing that Idiot Disciple has better than me:
Empathy. I didn't realize it myself. He has
almost no
autonomy. He entrusts everything he has to others he feels are his relatives. Maybe that's why.  That's because he's
a few steps above me in terms of his attunement with the dead. He
doesn't care in the slightest if he's covered in dirt, but
when his place of dependence is defiled,
he and the
Shrine of the Dead
become unstoppable.